Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass – was ist los in la Liga, der Premier League, der Serie A und der Liga A? Diese Frage wollen wir heute beantworten in der Ligatur in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 245. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das hier ist die Ligatur. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen auf den europäischen Männerfußball blicken. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Etge Netzer. Auf Twitter und auf mastodon.social freue ich mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr auf unsere Runde, die heute besteht aus. Zum einen Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli. Dann ist noch Nils Kern hier. Hallo Nils. Schöne Grüße. Marius Soyke ist hier. Hallo, Marius.
Moin aus dem verregneten Norden an alle euch im Süden.
Ja, also ich habe hier gerade Sonne. Wir können ja gleich ein ganz gutes Stimmungsbild erzeugen, denn wir wissen auch gleich, wie das Wetter in Nürnberg ist, denn wir haben hier zum ersten Mal mit dabei. Ich freue mich sehr. Michael Postl vom Kicker Hallo Michi. Na, siehste. Genau. Bayern liefert mal wieder, möchte ich sagen. Ja, dann lasst uns doch gleich loslegen. Vorher muss ich allerdings noch eine Bemerkung loswerden. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Ihr wisst es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, oder solltet es zumindest wissen. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und gerade diejenigen, die so gerne die Ligatour hören und vielleicht sonst gar nicht so oft in den Rasenfunk reinhören, euch brauchen wir jetzt. Also die mehr Energie, die in den Rasenfunk fließt, die wird sich vor allem bei der Ligatour bemerkbar machen und die wird sich bei der 2. Männer-Bundesliga bemerkbar machen. Das heißt, wenn ihr diese Formate gern konsumiert und sonst vielleicht gar nicht die Zeit habt, dann überlegt doch mal, ist euch das vielleicht 2 Euro, 3 Euro, vielleicht 5 Euro im Monat wert, dann hätten wir höhere Einnahmen damit und könnten eben unsere Gästehorne horare erholen, die wir zwar schon zahlen und davon nicht zu knapp, weil wir so viele Gäste haben, aber die Einzelsummen, die sind eben noch nicht so hoch, wie wir es gerne hätten, da würden wir uns gerne verbessern. Also rasenfunk.de supporters.club, da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Jetzt gehen wir rein in die Ligatour. Ihr habt mir wie immer jeweils zwei Themen mitgebracht. Nils, wir wollen mal mit dir beginnen, denn in La Liga, da gibt es im Pokal eine richtig große Überraschung. Welche denn?
Ja, die Überraschung ist, dass ein kleiner Underdog mal wieder dabei ist. Der Club Atletico Ossasuna spielt jetzt auch schon wieder eine Weile in der ersten Liga. Seit 2019 sind sie wieder aufgestiegen und ja, mischen da so ein bisschen die Copa del Rey auf und haben ganz gute Chancen, zum zweiten Mal überhaupt in ihrer Vereinsgeschichte seit 2005 ins Finale einzuziehen, haben am Mittwoch das erste Halbfinale-Hinspiel mit 1-0 gegen den Athletic Club gewonnen und an sich ist das generell auch ein besonderes Finale, denn das wissen vielleicht auch viele Zura Zura-Rinnen nicht. Das Halbfinale dieses Jahr ist sehr besonders, weil dort sind drei Liga-Dinos vertreten mit Real Madrid Barcelona, dem Athletic Club, vier Mitglieder geführte Vereine aus der Liga, in der Liga gibt es generell nur fünf Mitglieder geführte Vereine, alles andere sind so Sport- Gesellschaften, das ist schon mal auch besonders, dass diese Clubs weiterkommen und generell weiß man natürlich auch zwischen dem Athletic Club und Osasuna viele Eigengewächse, eine besondere Philosophie, speziell der Athletic Club setzt ja nur Spiele aus dem Baskenland ein und auch Osasuna hat jede Menge Eigengewächse, also nicht so diese Clubs, die ständig nur Transfers veranstalten und viele Legionäre haben, sondern schon ein besonderes Duell.
Ja, also da haben wir jetzt ja dann auch den Klassikoo, jetzt dann am heutigen Donnerstag, wir nehmen auf am 2. März. Ist denn das jetzt Zufall, ist es einfach ein guter Run, den Osasuna da hat oder steht das für mehr? Wenn ich mir die Tabelle angucke, dann sind sie da auf Rang 8, mit allerdings noch Kontakt zum Rang 6, über den man ja auch ins internationale Geschäft käme.
Ja, da diese Plätze für Conference Leagues natürlich gut umkämpft, Osasuna hat sogar einen Punkt mehr als der Athletik Club. Das ist schon besonders und steht auf jeden Fall für etwas mehr. Das ist nicht nur eine Überraschungssaison jetzt an sich in der Liga, denn Osasuna steht absolut für das Thema Konstanz. Die haben jetzt eben, seit sie in die 2. Liga abgestiegen sind, haben sie ihren Trainer, Yaguba Arasate, der ist mit 44 Jahren noch gar nicht so alt und hat sie direkt in die 1. Liga zurückgeführt. Dort hat man sich eigentlich stetig verbessert und ist aktuell mit dem Punkteschnitt – wäre man auf einem Punkterekord aus, wenn man natürlich den Schnitt beibehält. Das sieht aktuell sehr gut aus und steht mal wieder dafür, dass man nicht immer gleich den Trainer wechseln muss, wenn es vielleicht mal schlecht läuft, dass man auch mal eine Mannschaft zusammenhalten kann, dass es auch zu Erfolg wird, wenn eine Mannschaft zusammengehalten wird. Da sind ja Real Sociedad oder Rayo Vallecan, die auch in der Tabelle weiter oben stehen. Ähnliche Beispiele, aber da eben Ossasuna mit auch natürlich irgendwo bestimmten Spielweise, ein paar hohe Bälle, dass die da sowohl hinten neutral sind und vorne ein paar Abnehmer haben. Ein Thiboudi, der mir weiß, wo das Tor steht, Chimi Avila, ist so ein bisschen Kultstürmer, Kike Gassir, auch viel Erfahrung. Sie haben mittlerweile auch Top-Talente, die sie halten können, wie Monka Yola, den sie mit einem sehr langen Vertrag ausgestattet hat. Also, sie sind schon schwer zu knacken, schwer zu knacken, auch wenn sie hier und da natürlich mal eine Niederlage gegen Real Madrid und Barcelona gibt. Aber sie stehen schon für mehr. Wie gesagt, Konstanz ist da ein großes Thema und das hackt man aktuell mit einem Trainer, der jetzt seit fünf Jahren da ist. Ich glaube, nur die große Simione ist noch länger im Amt in der Liga.
Aber das heißt, er ist dann auch gekommen in der Abstiegssaison oder war er schon, also hat er quasi die komplette Abstiegssaison auch zu verantworten und sie haben dennoch an ihm festgehalten?
Nein, das ist jetzt nicht. Er kam in der 2. Liga da im Sommer 2018. Dann waren sie gerade abgestiegen und dann hat er sie direkt wieder hochgeführt.
Jetzt dachte ich schon, dann wäre die Geschichte noch besser gewesen. Nur vier Legionäre hat Osasuna in seinem Kader. Also das, was du jetzt gerade schon angesprochen hast mit den jungen spanischen Talenten, war das schon immer die Ausrichtung dieses Teams und mir Kultur über Nausen war das einfach nicht bewusst oder hat da auch eine Veränderung eingesetzt?
Ja, an sich Vereine im Baskenland, ob es der Athletik-Club ist, Reyes-Foçada oder auch jetzt eben Osasuna aus Pamplona, haben schon immer natürlich eine besondere Philosophie, dass sie auch eigene Spieler oder eigene Talente setzen, wo natürlich nicht immer so ein ganz hoher Ertrag vielleicht auch war, speziell bei Osasuna. Also du hattest schon auch mal in der Vergangenheit eine höhere Legionärsquote und jetzt mittlerweile eben die Spieler, die da sind und vielleicht nicht aus Spanien kommen wie Ante Budimir, Cimia Villa, die schlagen dann eben auch ein. Also da hat man eine gute Mischung einfach gefunden und mittlerweile da ist die Konstanz da, weil die Mannschaft ist jetzt schon seit einigen Jahren zusammengewachsen, ohne dass da sehr viel Veränderungen im jedem Jahr ist. Klar geht immer mal, einer kommt, einer meugt, es kam jetzt aus Villarreal, aber auch die kommen irgendwie, passen, fügen sich nahtlos ein und deswegen ist das aktuell ein sehr stimmiges Bild. Natürlich auch die Infrastruktur des Vereins passt, man hat das Stadion El Sadar modernisiert, das ist eins der Stadien mit den steilsten Rängen, das hat man auch im Vokal-Halbfinale gesehen, dass dort ein guter Hexenkessel entstehen kann, auch wenn das Spiel an sich nur jetzt eine richtige Chance für Osasuna ergeben hat. Die haben dann 1-0 gewonnen, die Athletik war ein bisschen mehr im Spiel vielleicht drin, aber Osasuna, wie gesagt, kann auch ganz gut verteidigen, hat hohe Innenverteidiger und kann auch ganz gut mitkämpfen. Und ja, diese Philosophie ist auf alle übergegangen und deswegen ist Osasuna eine der wenigen Happy Stories aus La Liga.
Nicht gleich schon in dein zweites Thema reinleiten, da kommen wir erst später zu. Aber jetzt, wo ich mal so drüber nachdenke, ich meine, das mit dem Baskenland, das ist natürlich, also der Max stellt seine Spanierfrage und dann fällt es ihm selber ein, wie dumm diese Frage eigentlich war. Danke, dass du es nicht hervorgekehrt hast. Es war einfach ganz normal geantwortet hast. Aber das ist ja wirklich eine Besonderheit der spanischen Liga. Ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, Marius, gibt es was Vergleichbares in der Serie A auch, dass es so Regionalvereine gibt, die dann, also es müssen ja nicht gleich so fast schon separatistische Tendenzen sein, weshalb man das macht, aber dass man eben so sehr auf Italiener setzt?
Tatsächlich gab es das mal als Silvio Berlusconi bei der AC Monza eingestiegen ist. Das hatte dann aber, glaube ich, politisch ein bisschen andere Gründe. Also da wollte er dann irgendwie im Zweifel Wählerstimmen mit abgreifen, dass man gesagt hat, okay, jetzt kommen nur noch Italiener und keine Tätowierten und keine Bärtigen und das sind auch wirklich die Wählerstimmen, die man gerne haben möchte. Ja, ja, ja. Und das ist dann ja relativ schnell auch wieder umgekehrt. Dann hat er Boatengo holt und Balotelli und dann war das schon wieder vorbei. Da wurde dann doch das politische Kalkül im sportlichen Erfolg untergeordnet. Aber nee, ansonsten ist die Serie A ja, glaube ich, eine der Top-Ligen mit den meisten ausländischen Spielern. Und klar gibt es einige, die setzen mehr auf die Jugend als andere. Aber so was, was man mit Athletik oder so vergleichen kann, das gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Premier League, Uli, muss ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so wirklich fragen. Ich tue es jetzt pro Forma.
Nein, mir ist nichts bekannt dergleichen. Also nicht mal im Entferntesten. Es gab mal Burnley, aber das war schon Deutschs eigener Einfall und fehlende Kassen. Aber sonst nichts Ideologisches dahinter oder sowas.
Also ich hätte jetzt auch Wolverhampton gelten lassen, aber halt quasi für portugiesischen Nachwuchsen. Das wäre auch noch in Ordnung gewesen. Michael, wie schaut es aus in der Ligue 1?
Also wirklich idealistisch ist da wenig. Wir kommen ja nachher noch mal auf Rennes zu sprechen. Da geht es schon darum, Talente aus der Britannie, also quasi links oben im Sechseck, dort Talente zu rekrutieren. Allerdings ist natürlich Caire-Fontaine nahe Paris, dieses Leistungszentrum, unfassbar viele Talente in den letzten Jahren, 30 Jahren ausgebildet worden. So das Zentrum der Talentschmiede. Da setzt man sehr auf die Jungs aus den Bordiers, aus den Vororten von Paris. Das klingt womöglich ein bisschen makaber, aber sie nutzen da diese sozialen Strukturen, die in diesen Gebieten herrschen. Es ist natürlich eine sozial schwache Gegend. Das beste Beispiel ist Kylian Mbappé, der in diesem Volupt groß geworden ist. Da gibt es dann eben wenig außer Fußball. Da rekrutieren die Franzosen dann ihre Talente, hat aber weniger diesen ideologischen Hintergrund, als diese soziale Struktur, die da herrscht. Dann schicken die Jungs nach Clairefontaine, haben einmal im Jahr ihre Sichtungstraining und dann kommen, glaube ich, 20 Talente. Die werden dann übernommen und werden dann geformt.
Genau, werden ausgebildet, aber auch anders als in Deutschland. Das habe ich bei Tobi Escher in seinem neuen Buch gelesen, was Teams erfolgreich macht. Da ist es ja so, dass die zwar dann in Clairefontaine ausgebildet werden, aber am Wochenende bei ihren Heimatvereinen spielen. Also ein großer Unterschied zu den Nachwuchsleistungszentren, die einen immer rausziehen aus dem Heimatverein. Aber wenn wir jetzt dann eh schon bei Frankreich sind, dann lass doch gleich mal über Rennen sprechen. Die hast du nämlich als eins von zwei Themen mitgebracht. Wenn ich die mir ansehe in der Tabelle, dann liegen die auf Rang 5. Damit spielt man international in der Ligue 1, haben zuletzt jetzt zweimal gewonnen, 46 Punkte. Sieht ehrlicherweise unspektakulär aus. Was ist denn das, was Rennen erwähnenswert macht?
Ja, das sind vor allem die Talent-Scouts, die immer wieder ein unglaubliches Händchen beweisen. Die besten Beispiele sind da eigentlich Eduardo Camavinga, der bei Real gelandet ist, ein Usman Dembélé, der jetzt bei Barca spielt, über Dortmund gekommen ist. Eduard Mondi ist zwar nicht in Rennen komplett ausgebildet worden, aber hat Jahre seiner Karriere dort verbracht, ist da groß geworden. Das sind nur ein paar Beispiele, also da könnte man diese Liste wirklich unendlich lang weiterführen. Jorginio Rütter übrigens, der damals in Hoffenheim gelandet ist, mit 18, 19 und jetzt in die Premier League gewechselt ist.
Auch durchaus freiwillig, was man so lesen kann. Da hat man überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt, sein Berater ist wirklich toll.
Richtig, wie nie in Hoffenheim. Das war dann vor ungefähr 25 Jahren. François Pinot war ein Multimillionär, ich glaube mittlerweile auch ein Multimilliardär. Aus der Britannien aber hat dann über seine Finanzholding Rennen gekauft und hat anfangs dann versucht, mit viel Geld den Kader aufzupappen, mit mehreren Südamerikanern auch. Da war einer dabei, den er aus dem Intermeiland rekrutiert hat, wurde schon mit Ronaldo verglichen. Anfang der 2000er war das noch ein Vergleich, den jeder mit dem Brasilianer Ronaldo verbunden hat.
Kennt man den noch, der da verglichen wurde und der da geholt wurde? Bei mir klingt jetzt gar nichts.
Nein, Luca Severino hieß der. War damals eben bei Intermeiland, aber keine große Nummer. Vor allem bei Rennen hat es nicht gefunkt. Hat keine großen Leistungen jetzt erbracht und naja gut, dann gab es eben diesen Paradigmenwechsel nach ein paar Jahren, weil er gemerkt hat, der Monsieur Pinot, dass es eben nicht so klappt. Er hat dann auf Talente aus der Britannien gesetzt und hat sehr viel Geld in die Jugendarbeit gesteckt. Ich glaube, das Budget lässt mich Lügen vervierfacht und seitdem ist es sehr konstant eben. Das ist so das Herzstück dieser Strategie. Da hat es dann angefangen und nach Pégé ist Rennes der Verein, der am meisten in seine Jugendarbeit steckt. Das ist ein Modell, das seit 20 Jahren Früchte trägt. Mittlerweile, ich glaube, in den letzten zehn Jahren gab es genau eine Saison, wo Rennes schlechter war als Platz 10 für so einen kleinen Verein, der aus einem sympathischen Verein in Frankreich die Rennes krass hassen. Das ist eine Universitätsstadt in Britannien, es ist ohnehin eine schöne Gegend und so. Also sehr pauschal runtergebrochen ist es jetzt kein unsympathischer Verein mit diesem Sponsor da im Rücken, natürlich, aber eben auf eine andere Weise. François Pinot hat dann die Geschäfte eben abgegeben an seinen Sohn, François Ré, Pinot heißt der, und der hat dann die Strategie weitergeführt seines Vaters. Er wird ziemlich verehrt in Rennes, weil er so einen Verein geschaffen hat, der auch immer wieder in der Europa League dabei ist, oder international zumindest, jetzt sehr unglücklich gescheitert gegen Donetsk. Die hätten gut und gerne auch weiterkommen können.
Das war das F-Meter-Schießen, wo schon das F-Meter-Schießen eigentlich Glück war für Donetsk, dass man da reingekommen ist, ne?
Genau, total. Ich hoffe, ich komme nicht zu work ins Schwärmen. Ich habe selber Zeit in Rennes verbracht und finde diese Stadt einfach wunderbar. Aber es ist ein Erfolgskonzept und steht eben im klassen Gegensatz zu Vereinen, die immer wieder unter anderem aus Amerika ihr Geld beziehen und von großen Sponsoren eben abhängen. Ganz im klassen Gegensatz natürlich zu PSG. Wobei PSG natürlich auch eine sehr starke Jugendarbeit hat, aber die sieht man dann eben nicht auf dem Platz, zumindest bei der ersten Mannschaft. Genau, das ist so das, was Rennes ausmacht und was Rennes aktuell – also nicht nur aktuell, sondern seit Jahren – zu einem sehr interessanten Club macht, weil sie es eben immer wieder schaffen, mit eigenen Talenten diese Riesentransfers, die sie tätigen. Es ist ja auch Mathis Tell, weil er um Worben in Europa, Bayern, hat dann den Zuschlag bekommen. Und auch da ist man sich sicher in Frankreich, dass Mathis Tell eine sehr große Karriere bevorsteht, auch wenn er die noch nicht so auf den Platz bringt, wie er es vielleicht in zwei Jahren tun wird.
Faszinierend. Und sehr schön, dass es noch so andere Modelle gibt, auch wenn – also ich habe mich so ein bisschen durch die Transferhistorie von Rennes jetzt durchgeklickt – da waren schon fantastische Transfers mit dabei. Es ist eine extrem schwierige Frage, aber vielleicht weiß ihr ja einer von euch vieren, wenn es jemand weiß, dann ihr. In der Saison 97, 98 sind ablösefrei zwei Bundesligaspieler aus der Bundesliga zu Rennen gewechselt. Wisst ihr zufällig, wer sie sind? Einer kam von Köln, einer von Werder, einer ist direkt danach weitergewechselt zu 1860 München. Also Patrick Weiser ist vom 1. FC Köln dorthin gewechselt und Bernd Hoppsch. Bernd Hoppsch ist damals von Werder zu Rennes und dann erst zu 60. Diese Zwischenstation hätte ich im Leben nicht mehr hinbekommen. Ist auch die Frage, warum man das hinbekommen will, außer man macht den Doppelsex-Podcast. Aber irgendwie kam ich an diesem Fakt nicht vorbei. Also Rennes, sehr schön, dass du uns da mal ein bisschen was zu erzählt hast. Dann lasst uns mal in die Premier League blicken. Uli, da hast du unter anderem mit Manchester United ein Thema mit dabei. Du hast mir gesagt, das ist ja fast schon zu langweilig. Und das stimmt, weil United ist jetzt quasi schon eine ganze Weile auf einer Erfolgswelle. Aber hier im Rasenfunk haben wir darüber noch nicht gesprochen. Das letzte Mal, dass wir über United gesprochen haben, da war noch alles schlecht. Und jetzt ist ja alles gut. Und man hat unter anderem Barca rausgehauen in der Europa League. Was ist denn da in der Zwischenzeit passiert?
Der erste Titel ist eingekehrt. Und das heißt bei United immer, dass man denkt, man sei auf dem Weg in die richtige Richtung. Und ich denke das auch, ehrlich gesagt, dass die Richtung auf alle Fälle die komplett richtige ist. Jetzt ist noch die Frage, wie nachhaltig kann das alles sein. Aber am Sonntag haben sie den EFL Cup gewonnen. Also der English Football League Cup ist vergleichbar mit dem Liga-Pokal. Ich mag die Übersetzung Liga-Pokal ins Deutsche, aber nicht, weil sie nicht ganz genau ist. Deswegen bleibe ich bei EFL Cup. Und das ist das erste Silber, das es im Jahr zu gewinnen gibt. Eigentlich auch im Fußballjahr, weil ich Community Shield immer nicht mitzähle. Und da haben sie jetzt am Sonntag das Finale gegen UCAS United recht souverän am Ende dann doch gewonnen. Und haben jetzt Silber mal wieder nach sechs Jahren in der Vitrine stehen.
Das ist ja die eine Sache. Das andere ist ja aber vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Ausblick in der Liga, oder? Also United hat sich vorgerobbt, bis auf Rang 3. Hat gerade acht komfortable Punkte Vorsprung auf einen Nicht-Champions-League-Platz. Früher wäre das eine Selbstverständlichkeit gewesen, aber genau darum geht es ja auch. Plus jenseits von irgendwelchen Qatar-Investments, die da noch anstehen, aber das ist vielleicht dann ein Thema für am Ende des Segments, scheint ja auch ansonsten da eine Ruhe eingekehrt zu sein, die untypisch ist für die letzten Jahre von United.
Ja, total. Also es gibt jemanden, der die sportliche Richtung vorgibt. Das ist der Trainer. Es gibt jemanden, der sie unterstützt. Das ist der Director of Football, den es hier jahrelang einfach gar nicht gab bei United. Und alle entsprechend – vielleicht hängt das auch zusammen, ich gehe fast davon aus – alle Transfers funktionieren, die gemacht werden. Es sei es jetzt die im Sommer, die ja noch Permanentdeals sind oder im Winter Slydeals, die beide funktionieren. Auch Ten Haag, der alles im Griff zu haben scheint, ist beliebt im Umfeld – sowohl bei Fans als auch Medien – und gibt die spielerische Richtung vor, die auch nicht immer die gleiche sein muss. Das funktioniert insofern auch gut, dass die Punkte kommen einerseits und zum anderen, dass man sehr glaubwürdig Leistungen vermitteln kann. Also egal, was Ten Haag da taktisch einzieht, es scheint von den Spielern angenommen zu werden. Zumindest besagt, dass die Leistungen entsprechend dann die Ergebnisse. Und deswegen hat man eine Art von Ruhe, an die kann ich mich auch lange nicht erinnern.
Okay, also wir haben Transversi funktionieren, wir haben Director of Football, wir haben einen erfolgreichen Trainer oder einen Trainer, der beliebt ist zumindest. Hat sich denn an der Spielweise von United auch was getan?
Ja, hat sich schon. Also im Vergleich zur letzten Saison ist es sehr viel ausgewogener. Also bei Ole Gunnar Solskjaer mit Verlaub war es ja eigentlich nur Kontern. Bei Ralf Rangnick war es am Anfang eine Art etwas Druck ausüben, dann Kontern, umschalten. Also so Leid, Leid, Leid, wie wir es in Deutschland von Leipzig kennen. Und am Ende war es dann einfach nur noch Chaos, weil niemand mehr mitgezogen hat. Und jetzt ist es inzwischen so, dass es spielerische Elemente gibt, teilweise auch Elemente aus dem alten Ajax-Fußball. Sie spielen im Mittelfeld Mann gegen Mann beispielsweise, versuchen schon von hinten raus sauber rauszukombinieren mit einem super spielstarken Lissandro Martinez. Den muss man glaube ich noch mal besonders hervorheben, der ziemlich sicher wahrscheinlich der beste spielende Verteidiger in der Premier League gerade ist. Und da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Leuten, die in Frage kämen, aber der ist einfach sehr, sehr stark. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Elemente, die Ten Hag eingezäumt hat. Also, wenn ihr euch mal zurück erinnert an ganz zu Beginn der Saison, da gab es diese hohe Niederlage gegen Brighton als alle schon dachten um Himmels willen. Ten Hag überlebte es auch nur ein paar Tage. Da gab es schon den Spitznamen Eric Ten-Mann, weil das eh nicht länger aushalten würde im Job.
Das ist ja fast Rasenfunk-Niveau, das ist kein Kompliment.
Ich finde das gut. Und dann hat er aber, Ten Hag, und das liebe ich sehr an Fußball-Trainerinnen, das festgestellt, dass das noch nicht so funktioniert, wie er sich das vorstellt, also dass er wirklich über den Platz verteilt eins gegen eins spielt, dass er total ins Pressing geht und hat eine Sicherheitsvariante eingezogen und hat der Mannschaft das gelassen, worin sie sich wohlfühlt, nämlich das Kontern hat sich eigentlich kontinuierlich ein paar Meter zurückgezogen, auf den Platz immer mal wieder dann neuere Elemente eingearbeitet, aber erstmal so eine Art pragmatisches Sicherheitssystem eingezogen, das voll funktioniert hat, dass ihm geholfen hat, dass die Spieler ihm glaubten und so hat man dann auch langsam angefangen Punkte zu holen, weil er ganz lange das einzige Team des Arsenal schlagen konnte und hat. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass sie es so gut wie möglich machen. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass sie es so gut wie möglich machen. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass sie es so gut wie möglich machen.
Sie merken, dass sie tun sollen, wenn sie es tun, funktioniert es. Ich hatte Manchester United mittlerweile schon fast abgeschrieben, weil jeder Trainer an diesem Kader verzweifelt ist. Dann haben sie immer wieder krasse Spieler geholt. Ich dachte mir, es muss auch jetzt mal funktionieren. Es hat aber nicht funktioniert. Überrascht es dich, dass sie jetzt die Ideen von Ten Hag so umsetzen können, wie sie es tun?
In der Art und Weise schon. Wie schnell es ging, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Mir war schon klar, dass Ten Hag funktionieren würde. Ich hielt den schon für einen der fähigsten Trainer und einer der spannendsten Persönlichkeiten im europäischen Fußball. Das war mir schon klar, dass das, wenn man ihm glaubt, eines Tages funktionieren würde. Ich habe aber zum Beispiel nicht damit gerechnet, dass Casimiro plötzlich solche Bälle spielt. Dass das ein Zerstörer ist, weiß Nils zum Beispiel ganz gut. Wir haben ja oft über den gesprochen bei Real Madrid, dass er wahrscheinlich der beste defensive Mittelfeldspieler ist. Ja, er spielt plötzlich Bälle, Pässe. Der bricht sämtliche Linien. Das habe ich nicht kommen sehen. Das ist auch untypisch gewesen bei United, dass Transfers funktioniert hätten. Es gab die Diskussion über Lissandro, ob er nicht zu klein sei. Daran habe ich auch nie geglaubt. Wir wollten alle lange nichts mehr von ihm hören, aber ich muss das jetzt noch einmal sagen. Es gab ja auch die ganze Cristiano-Ronaldo-Saga im November, Dezember, als das losging. Da hat Ten Hag, glaube ich, clever gespielt und gewonnen, indem er den Machtkampf so lange rausgezögert hat, bis er wusste, dass der andere durchdrehen wird und dann kann er ihn rauskicken. Auch da ist er im Übrigen unterstützt worden vom Verein, was vorher auch nicht normal war. Der Trainer davor hatte auch die Überlegung, aber wusste, das kann er nicht bringen, weil das Standing im Verein nicht da ist. Deshalb ist die Antwort schon. Ich bin auch in der Schnelligkeit, im Tempo schon überrascht, wie schnell das ging. Am Ende aber war mir schon klar, dass es funktionieren könnte, wenn der Verein nicht die Manchester United-Dinge der letzten Jahre macht.
Ja krass. Ich fand es auch sehr überraschend. Welche Rolle spielt denn eigentlich der Jadon Sancho? Ich habe im Kopf, dass er lange nicht gespielt hat, aber die letzten Spiele dann doch wieder. Jetzt, wo es unter anderem weg vom Konterfußball geht, ist er dann trotzdem ein Faktor im Team?
Jetzt wieder. Er hat auch ein paar Mal sehr ordentlich gespielt, war aber von Anfang November bis Anfang Februar raus. Anfang Februar stimmt sicher. Ich glaube aber Anfang November ist die Zeit, da hat ihn Ten Hag ins Eigentrainingslager in die Niederlande geschickt. Man weiß immer nicht so ganz genau bei ihm, warum. Bei Ten Hag ist ein Sammelbegriff, der heißt Illness. Wenn jemand mental nicht ganz auf der Höhe ist, ist er ill bei ihm. Man hört aus Manchester, dass er mit Senshos Leistungen nicht zufrieden war, mit seiner Gesamtattitüde und Einstellungen nicht zufrieden war. Er hat ihm deshalb auch gesagt, komm mal zu dir. Lass mal den Druck weg runterkommen und fang an Spaß am Fußball zu haben. Und komm dann zurück in die Mannschaft. Auch das ist ja dann immer ein Indikator, wenn so jemand zurückkommt und plötzlich dann direkt Leistung bringt. Hat funktioniert.
Richtiger Schachzug. Hat ja auch lange gedauert bei ihm.
Und die Erfolgs-Serie ist wirklich krass. In den letzten 32 Pflichtspielen nur zwei Niederlagen. Einmal gegen Arsenal, knapp 2 zu 3. Und einmal gegen City, damit ging es los im Oktober. 3 zu 6, das war deutlich. Wie United rollt, ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Und irgendwann habe ich noch das Wort abgeschnitten.
Alles gut. So ein bisschen die Entwicklung von Markus Rushford ist ja auch stellvertretend dafür. Der schießt ja im Moment alles ab. Und klar hat man immer gewusst, dass der super talentiert ist. Aber der lebt ja auch in den letzten Jahren extrem unter der Entwicklung im Verein, oder?
Ja, da waren natürlich auch noch ein paar persönliche Dinge mit drin nach der Europameisterschaft. Das hat ihn wohl sehr getroffen, als er besonders rassistisch beleidigt worden ist. Aber ja, es gibt zwei Gewinner aus der ganzen Ronaldo-Sache. Das ist zum einen Erik Ten Haag. Dann kommt ganz, ganz lange nichts. Und dann kommt wahrscheinlich Markus Rushford, weil der den Großteil der Schüsse abbekommen hat. Man könnte jetzt immer noch sagen, er kriegt immer noch zu viel. Weil wenn man dem jetzt, der inzwischen, also Rushford deutlich stärker ist auf der linken Seite als auf der neuner Position, was sie auch nie vermöglich hielt, wenn man dem jetzt noch eine echte Nummer neun zur Verfügung stünde, der auch aus mehreren Winkeln abschlussstark sein könnte, also Ossi Mann ist ja kein Geheimnis, das ist der große Wunschspieler von Erik Tenach, dann wäre das noch besser. Aber ja, Rushford ist unglaublich. Da sieht man mal, was in dem Typen alles drin ist, wie der plötzlich wieder sowohl das Tempo bringt, als auch die Schussstärke mit sich bringt. Das wussten wir, dass er sie hat, aber das ist alles freigesetzt vom unbändigen Selbstvertrauen, das plötzlich bei ihm da ist. Da hat Erik Tenach einen riesengroßen Anteil daran, wie an so vielen – das ist jetzt gemein, das zu sagen – aber fast Auferstehungen in dem Kader. Aaron Wan-Bissaka ist wahrscheinlich das allerbeste Beispiel, der einfach nie mehr gespielt hat unter keinem der Trainer, weil er auch teilweise selbst darum gebeten hat, nicht spielen zu müssen. Der fällt auch unter diesen Bereich Illness. Er hat große private Probleme. Ich möchte die jetzt nicht großartig breit treten, aber da stimmt wenig im Leben des jungen Mannes. Und nach der WM musste er ran auf der rechtsverteidiger Seite. Ich habe das erste Spiel damals gemacht und habe mir gedacht, um Gottes Willen, das geht schief, weil ich ziemlich genau wusste, woran es bei ihm hakt. Und er fängt plötzlich an, solide zu spielen. Das ist jetzt nicht Weltklasse, aber er spielt solide und hatte seinen Anteil auch am Sonntag, dass das klappte. Und das sind so Dinge, die Eric Denhaag offensichtlich gut zu machen scheint. Man to Man-Management, sagt man ja in England. Das scheint er offensichtlich sehr gut zu machen.
Und das unterscheidet ja vielleicht die Großen von den ganz großen Trainern. Wir sind gespannt, wie es da weitergeht. Die Zahlen zu Markus Reschfords neuem Erfolg will ich euch noch kurz nachliefern, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. In 39 Pflichtspielen, 25 Tore und 7 Assists, also 32 Torbeteiligung in 39 Spielen. Das ist mal Erquötsche. Das kann sich sehen lassen, wie der Hesse bestimmt nicht so sagen würde wie ich, aber es war zumindest der Versuch. Und jetzt haben wir es geschafft, so viel über Sportliches zu reden. Katar können wir jetzt nicht mehr machen, aber da wird es vielleicht auch nochmal was Längeres geben im Rasenfunk, wenn eine Entscheidung da ist. Vorher ist es viel Spekulation. Das hatten wir bei Chelsea letztes Jahr auch schon. Warten wir erstmal ab, was da kommt und schauen wir stattdessen mal in die Serie A. Wir haben Marius gerade schon gehört. Jetzt darf er auch mal länger erzählen. Vielleicht beginnen wir mal mit dem Thema, das in der letzten Woche anschließt, Marius. Da hat uns Christian Bernhardt in der letzten Folge, natürlich vor zwei Wochen, noch erzählt, wie turbulent die Wochen bei Milan gerade gelaufen sind. Mit Gegentorflut, großer Verunsicherung. Man hat in einem Monat so viele Gegentore kassiert wie zuletzt in den 1920ern. Und jetzt willst du mir verkaufen, Marius, dass Milan sich wieder erholt hat. Was ist da passiert? Das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Der aufgeregte italienische Fußball, sage ich mal, ist ein ganz klassisches Beispiel. Da ist ja dann auch schon zumindest ein bisschen vorsichtig über Stefano Pioli, den Meistertrainer, diskutiert worden. Nachdem es – ich habe hier die Ergebnisse gerade nochmal vorliegen – 2-2 gegen die Roma. Das war noch so einigermaßen okay. Da haben sie erst in der Schlussphase den Gegentreffer bekommen. Aber dann 2-2 gegen Lecce, 0-4 gegen Lazio, 2-5 gegen Sassuolo, dann das Derby gegen Inter verloren, in der Coppa dann auch nochmal gegen Inter verloren. Und da dachte man so, ja, Pioli, das ist so ein Rückfall in alte Muster in seinen vergangenen Stationen. Da hat er am Anfang immer sehr gut gearbeitet, mit dem Team gut funktioniert. Und dann kam irgendwann diese Krise und die konnte er nicht überwinden. Und das ist ja auch das, worüber Christian Bernhardt so ein bisschen gesprochen hat. Und dann war die Sicherheit weg. Das Verständnis oder die Verbindung zwischen Mittelfeld und Abwehr hat nicht mehr funktioniert. Dann ist auch noch Tommori ausgefallen, verletzt. Und dann hat Pioli aber gezeigt, dass er sich weiterentwickelt hat als Trainer. Er hat die Taktik umgestellt von der Viererkette auf die Dreierkette. Er hat das alles massierter im Zentrum dargestellt und hat vor allem Malik Csau, der ja im Sommer aus Schalke gekommen ist, reingeworfen, weil Tommori auch verletzt war. Er hat mit ihm als zentraler Spieler in der Dreierkette gespielt. Plötzlich ist Milan seit vier Spielen ohne Gegentor. Er hat jetzt am Wochenende Atalanta geschlagen, die ja auch offensiv sehr, sehr stark sind. Er hat gegen die Spurs gewonnen in der Champions League, was man jetzt vielleicht auch nicht nach dieser Niederlagen oder Gegentor-Flut-Serie vermutlich gehalten hätte, so unbedingt. Und von daher hat er mit einem einfachen taktischen Kniff das Ruder herumgerissen und plötzlich ist die Sicherheit komplett wieder da. Also Atalanta, die ja gerade gegen die großen Mannschaften in Italien immer mit ihrem extremen Pressing sehr, sehr gute Ergebnisse geholt haben. Auch in den letzten anderthalb Jahren, wo es vielleicht nicht mehr so gut läuft wie noch vor zwei, drei Jahren, als man noch in der Champions League dann ins Viertelfinale gekommen ist. Aber gerade gegen die Großen sah das eigentlich immer sehr, sehr gut aus. Milan hat denen überhaupt gar keinen Stich gelassen. Christian Bernhardt hatte das Spiel auch als Co-Kommentator begleitet und hat immer dieses Wort Intensität benutzt. Was Milan auch ausgezeichnet hatte im letztes Jahr in der Meistersaison, genau das hat man komplett wieder gespürt. Die Spieler zerreißen sich wieder füreinander für den Mitspieler. Wenn einer den Ball verliert, ist sofort der Nächste da auf dem Gegenspieler. Auch vorne funktioniert das wieder viel lockerer. Man merkt bei Leao die Spielfreude wieder viel mehr als vor vier Wochen. Es ist natürlich ein Sinnbild für die Schnellewigkeit des Fußballs, was ich eingangs schon mal gesagt hatte. Dass man nach drei Spielen schon diskutiert, jetzt funktioniert gar nichts mehr. Aber man muss einfach festhalten, dass das Ruder herumgerissen wurde und plötzlich es wieder relativ rosig aussieht.
Und dieser Umschwung, das hat Christian quasi schon angedeutet. Über Dreiecke haben wir das letzte Mal schon gesprochen gegen Inter im Stadttorbi. Da lief das noch so. Na ja, da hat man ja auch verloren. Da war das Problem, dass man offensiv absolut harmlos war. Aber wenn man sich jetzt nicht nur diese vier Spiele und der Gegentor, sondern das waren ja auch Spiele. 0, 8, 0, 5, 0, 5 und 0, 1 waren die Expected Goals des Gegners. Also spricht das da eine Null-Stand? War jetzt nicht irgendwie der Toi, der ist über sich herausgewachsen, sondern die haben einfach wirklich gar nichts zugelassen. Und gerade jetzt gegen Atalanta am Wochenende, das ist schon echt erdrückend. Wie wird denn das jetzt diskutiert? Das ist ja interessant, dass wir diese Krise haben, die ja eindeutig eine war, haben wir ja das letzte Mal besprochen. Dann die taktische Umstellung, die sehr kritisch begleitet wurde, also gerade nach dem Stadterby. Das hat uns Christian auch noch das letzte Mal erzählt. Gibt es da jetzt dann einen schnellen Umschwung? Wie ist das? Ich glaube, in Deutschland gäbe es jetzt gleich die Experten, die sagen, ich habe immer gesagt, Dreierkette ist das so eine richtige Dinge. Wie ist das in Italien?
Ich glaube, so groß diskutiert wird es gar nicht mehr. Die Stimmung ist einfach grundsätzlich wieder positiv. Nach den Gründen, dass da jetzt wöchentlich groß ins taktische Detail gegangen wird, das sehe ich zumindest nicht. Ich lese natürlich jetzt auch nicht jedes Medium in Italien, aber ich finde es eigentlich, es ist wieder Ruhe eingekehrt im Grunde einfach. Jetzt hat man dann auch noch die Sachen, die die Schlagzeilen bestimmen, dass das Ibrahimovic auf den Platz zurückgekehrt ist, dass Mike Mignon, der Torwart, auch wieder da ist. Das ist so ein bisschen mehr im Vordergrund. Und um die Personalie, Pioli und was er taktisch so veranstaltet, ist es aus meiner Perspektive relativ ruhig geworden.
Das ist ja die Art von Ruhe, die man haben möchte. Also wir halten fest, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir müssen uns keine Sorgen mehr um Milan machen. Das scheint wieder zu laufen. Punktgleich ist man gerade mit Inter auf Rang 3. Und Napoli fliegt davon mit 18 Punkten. Jetzt unter anderem bei Inter verloren, hat am Wochenende und Napoli einfach nicht aufhören kann, zu gewinnen, wie wir unter anderem auch gesehen haben, jetzt unter der Woche. Gegen Eintracht Frankfurt in der Champions League. Einfach beeindruckend. Was da läuft über Napoli, werden wir ganz sicher auch noch sprechen an dieser Stelle. Dann lasst uns nochmal zu La Liga blicken. Nils hat uns noch ein Wohlfühlthema hatten wir mit Osasuna. Und jetzt hast du so ein allgemeines Liga-Thema mitgebracht. La Liga-Probleme. Ich habe neulich eine Statistik gesehen, ich habe sie jetzt leider nicht mehr gefunden. Aber es gibt unglaublich viele Platzverweise, unter anderem in der spanischen Liga. Ich habe hier noch einen Tweet, der ist allerdings jetzt vom 31. Dezember. Da war es so, in der Bundesliga gab es 8 direkte Platzverweise, in der Premier League 9, in der Serie A18, in La Liga damals 42. Und ich weiß, dass da noch einige mit dazu gekommen sind. Ist das Teil dieser La Liga-Probleme? Was meinst du mit diesem allgemeinen Punkt?
Ja, ich bin ja hier auch so als La Liga-Experte, muss vielleicht auch ein bisschen Werbung für La Liga machen, für meinen Podcast Tiki Taka und so weiter, und sagen, hey, geschaut La Liga, aber ich tu mich da mehr und mehr schwer, denn ja. Unter anderem die Platzverweise sind natürlich gestiegen. Wir sind jetzt in der Liga allein bei 94 Stück. Das ist mehr als in den anderen vier Top-Ligen zusammen. Die stehen dann bei 89, zum Beispiel Bundesliga 29. Entsprechend gibt es auch die meisten Fouls, auch die geringste Netto-Spielzeit, weil da doch viel Zeitschinderei im Fokus ist. Das hat jede Liga, jede Mannschaft, ich weiß. Aber in La Liga wird das in den letzten Monaten, eigentlich auch Jahre, mehr und mehr auf die Spitze getrieben. Viele Statistiken, viele Statisten sagen einfach, oh mein Gott, was ist da los? Auch hinsichtlich der meisten Tore, also 2, 4 Tore im Schnitt pro Partie. Zum Vergleich, die Bundesliga 3, 2, also auch das ist der schwächste Wert in La Liga, in den Top-Ligen. Das Gleiche auch bei den ältesten Spielern, die man hat, mit 27, 7 im Schnitt. Danke dann natürlich an Transfermarkt für die Daten. In der Bundesliga sind es zum Beispiel 26, 0. Du hast ja einfach mehr gefühlt mittlerweile Treter als Techniker auf dem Platz. Und wenn du mal neue Topstars hast, wenigstens ist er der wertvollste Spieler der Liga, dann muss der sich teilweise noch rassistischen Beleidigungen aussetzen und muss dann selbst noch La Liga anprangern von wegen, Rassisten dürfen weiter in die Stadien gehen und La Liga tut nichts dagegen. Danach hat La Liga doch ein bisschen was gezeigt, oder der Verband zumindest, was sie dagegen tun und dass sie jetzt die Maßnahmen erhöht haben mit Mitarbeitern, die bei riskanten Spielen vor Ort sind, um mehr aufzudecken. Da gab es jetzt schon ein paar Geldstrafen, auch gegen einzelne Fans, die in Mallorca waren oder in Valladolid. Viele, viele Sachen, die einfach nicht so schön sind in La Liga, die irgendwie die letzten Jahre, seitdem auch natürlich viele Topstars gegangen sind, ob das Neymar, Messi, Ramos, Christiane und viele andere waren, wo man sich schwer tut, dann die Spiele einzuschalten. Weil einfach auch das Entertainment-Paket mit wenigen Toren und wenig Spielzeit und viele Fouls und Karten überschaubar ist.
Okay, da war jetzt so viel drin. Lass mal, weil wir eingestiegen sind mit den Karten, bei den Karten kurz bleiben. Also 94 Platzverweise ist ja absolut irre. Ich sehe hier, dass es allein zwei Teams gibt, die über zehn Platzverweise hatten. Elche hat elf Platzverweise in den bisherigen Spielen einsammeln können. Ich wollte es gerade schon mit den Toren vergleichen, das waren nämlich 17, aber immerhin hat man da noch mehr. Real Betis 10 Platzverweise. Und es gibt kein einziges Team, das noch keinen Platzverweis eingesammelt hat. Also sehr, sehr viel. Hat das auch mit der Art zu schießen zu tun? Oder ist es wirklich das, was du gesagt hast, mit den vielen Fouls, mit den Tretern statt Technikern?
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen eine Mischung von beiden Fouls und Karten gehören dazu, aber es ist schon ganz offensichtlich sehr extrem in der Liga. Und man hat natürlich, ich glaube, jeder schimpft in seiner Liga so, wir haben echt keine guten Schiedsrichter. Aber gefühlt ist es wirklich so, dass in der Liga nicht unbedingt vielleicht die Schiedsrichter die beste Ausbildung und Qualifikation genossen haben. Oder da kommt jetzt natürlich noch ein anderes Thema dazu, dass in den letzten Jahren nicht unbedingt immer die besten Schiedsrichter befördert wurden. Es gab ja jetzt einen Schiedsrichter, eh klar, einen Skandal, dass eben der FC Barcelona von 2001 bis 2018 einem dem damaligen bis 2018 Vizepräsidenten des Schiedsrichterkomitees 7 Millionen Euro überwiesen hat für Schiedsrichterberatung. Das ist an sich nicht verwerflich. Ich glaube, das hat jeder Verein, um sich irgendwie für auf gewisse Schiedsrichter vorzubereiten. Nur eben damalige Trainer wie Ernesto Valverde, Tata Martino, wussten gar nichts von dieser Leistung. Das ist schon mal sehr dubios. Diese Person war dann eben verantwortlich für gewisse Schiedsrichterbeförderung. Wer darf 1. Liga? Wer darf 2. Liga pfeifen? Wer kriegt mal ein Pokalfinale? Da ist ein großes Geschmäck, das die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt, auch wenn da jetzt noch nicht unbedingt Konsequenzenfolgen abzusehen sind. Aber ja, es ist nicht nur das Schiedsrichter-Thema, sondern auch gefühlt viele mehr Treter als Techniker. Das ist so meine Aussage mittlerweile, weil man eben auch mehr auf einen – man holt sich dann eher lieber einen All-Star-Papu Gomes als auf eigene Talente auch zu setzen. Auch da ist es sehr überschaubar in La Liga, dass da einfach, wenn dann mal überhaupt Talente kommen, dann werden sie, ja, gehen sie nach England. Und wenn sie da nicht sind, dann kommen sie zurück. Brian Chil, Sergio Reguilón, Ferran Torres sind zurück. Wohingegen Spieler, die einschlagen, die irgendwie in ein Rodri bei Manchester City, die bleiben dann eher. Also da wird auch ganz gut abgekauft, wenn mal was Gutes bei La Liga rumkommt. Es ist einfach generell keine gute Entwicklung mit den Schiedsrichtern, mit wenigen Talenten, mit dann eben auch finanziell angeschlagenen Vereinen, die schnell eher mal einen erfahrenen Spieler ausleihen, um irgendwie das 0 zu 0 zu halten und nur als einem wertvollen Spieler wie Petri, wie Vinicius W tun, Hauptsache das Spiel zerstören. Ja, was nicht so schön ist.
Wie war denn das vorher in Spanien? Vor der Saison gab es eine Ansage auch an die Schiedsrichter. Hatte ich so im Hinterkopf irgendwie, dass unter anderem auch schlecht das Benehmen und so gegenüber den Schiris gerade auch von der Bank, glaube ich, mehr geahndet werden soll? Stimmt das oder ist das ein Faktor da?
Ob es diese Aussage gab, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr, aber gefühlt fallen auch da viele Karten Richtung Karten, die jetzt da gar nicht unbedingt in diese Statistik einfließen. Also die 11 Platzverweise bei Elche und 10 bei Betis sind jetzt eher rein auf die Spieler, die auf dem Platz waren. Aber ja, auch da ist einfach immer viel Polemik dabei, immer sehr viel Aufregung. Allein als jetzt Real Madrid auf Mallorca gespielt hat, da war ich noch dabei, da gab es allein 29.000 natürlich Hexenkessel-Stimmung gegen alles, was irgendwie, wenn der Gegner am Ball ist, wird direkt gepfiffen. Was ja irgendwo logisch ist, was dazu gehört, alle Provokationen gehören dazu. Aber eben, wo manche Schiedsrichter dann auch so ein bisschen das Spitzengefühl verloren geht, um irgendwie eine Partie richtig zu leiten und dann eben auch oft gar nicht mal groß mit sich diskutieren lassen, wenn dann der Kapitän zu ihnen kommt, da ist so Mateo Laos so ein berühmtes Beispiel, dass er einfach da sehr beratungsresistent ist und dann noch schneller eine gelbe Karte zückt. Also ja, auch da ist irgendwie, einfach hat man einfach die Karten viel zu locker sitzen und so, das stört dann natürlich auch ein flüssiges Spiel und fördert dann vielleicht noch mehr, dass noch mehr der Kontakt gesucht wird im Strafraum und noch mehr Theatralik von den Spielern zu sehen ist, wenn sie irgendwo nur den leichten Kontakt spüren.
Das ist übrigens auch in Frankreich der Fall. Ich hatte diese Aussage eben im Kopf, weil ich damals diese Thematik auch für Frankreich aufgegriffen hatte, weil Frankreich kurz hinter der La Liga rangiert bei den Roten Karten. Da gab es vor ein paar Wochen 65, ich weiß nicht, wie viele es jetzt sind. Da lag auch viel am Eingreifen des VAR. Also Schiris wurden zuvor auch darauf gepolt, bei härteren Fouls mehr durchzugreifen. Und der VAR sollte selbst bei kleinen Zweifeln dann zu Rate gezogen werden. Und dann mehrt sich natürlich die Kritik. Und zweitens werden dann gelbe Karten viel früher gezogen als zuvor noch. Und das hat dann so eben diese Auswirkung, dass irgendwie keiner zufrieden ist. Und dann gab es auch Änderungen an der Spitze des Schiedsrichterwesens. Also da gab es Konsequenzen. Soweit ist es bei der Liga, glaube ich, noch nicht. Aber es scheint dann auch ein bisschen anders zu sein.
Vielleicht gibt es da die Konsequenzen jetzt aus anderen Gründen, wenn man das mit den 7 Millionen Euro und was da vielleicht ja auch noch von anderen gezahlt wurde, ist zumindest interessant, wie sich real verhält. Das könnte man mit dem Problem, mit dem Verband beschreiben, wie sich real verhält, könnte aber auch andere Gründe haben. Ich werde mal einen Artikel von Sid Lowe aus dem Guardian verlinken in den Journals, die wir hören und hören. Ich finde, er hat das sehr, sehr gut zusammengefasst, wie viele Fragen einfach offen noch sind, ohne dass man da jetzt vorverurteilen muss und welchen Gesamteindruck das macht. Aber auch deshalb könnte sich bei den Schiedsrichtern vielleicht ein bisschen was verändern in Zukunft. Jetzt haben wir ja bisher oft es so gehabt. Oft sind die nationalen Ligen ja schon auch ein bisschen ein Abbild des Spielstils eines Landes, der sich dann eben auch im Nationalteam widerspiegelt. Würdest du denn sagen, das läuft jetzt auseinander? Denn mir wäre das jetzt bei sowohl beim Männer- als auch beim Frauen-Nationalteam ist mir das noch nicht aufgefallen, dass viel getreten wird. Und gerade die Frauen spielen einen ganz fantastischen Fußball. Es ist jetzt nicht das Zeichen für einen größeren Trend, sondern wahrscheinlich eher so eine Bestandsaufnahme, dass es aktuell von der Spielkultur her ein bisschen weniger schön ist.
Ja, man setzt halt doch eher aktuell auf den schnellen Erfolg. Viele Leihspieler, viele erfahrene Spieler und irgendwie nicht das Risiko eingehen, auf Talents zu setzen. Irgendwo hatten natürlich auch der spanische Fußball, sowohl die Liga als auch die Nationalmannschaft, hatte einen enormen Peak vor 10, 11, 12 Jahren. Ob das die Klassikus waren, ob das die vielen Titel der Nationalmannschaft waren, der so natürlich auch schwer zu wiederholen, schwer zu halten ist, speziell, wenn dann andere Ligen einfach noch viel, viel, viel mehr Geld haben und dann eben Topstars holen können. Trotzdem ist der aktuelle Jahrgang der Nationalmannschaft ein guter, aber jetzt auch nicht die absolute Weltklasse. Natürlich ein Roterlin, ein Petri muss man da nennen, die schon an der Weltklasse sind. Andere Spieler eben noch nicht so, egal ob sie älter sind, jünger sind. Frauenfußball ist nochmal was anderes, der boomt durchaus in Spanien und zieht viele Fans an. Und ist dann eben auch so, weil er noch bezahlbarer ist. Auch das ist ein La-Liga-Problem. Ich meine, jetzt ist Donassar Raben das Klassiko, da gehen die Preise von 100 bis 410 Euro im Benabeum, Camp Nou wird es genauso sein. Und das ist dann eben auch bei anderen Vereinen und Stadien so, egal wer da spielt, dass sich Männerfußball nicht mehr jeder leisten kann, dass es mehr auf Touristen gesetzt wird. Aber die sportliche Entwicklung würde ich schon sagen, dass das keine gute ist, weil man eben, wie gesagt, wenig auf Talente setzt, dass die Ausbildung da auch, ja, vielleicht nicht so ist, wie das in anderen Ligen der Fall ist, ohne dass ich da jetzt ein konkretes Beispiel nennen kann, weil einfach viel zu wenig durchkommt. Und wie gesagt, wenn mal was Gutes da ist, wird es gleich wieder aufgekauft. Und was nicht gut ist, hält sich dann in der Premier League. Und ansonsten wird es wieder abgestoßen wie in Ferran Torres oder jetzt auch Guedes, auch wenn der Portugieser ist ja auch schon wieder von den Wohlwänden weggewechselt. Also, La Liga kann gute Spieler bildet kaum noch aus und kann gute Spieler kaum noch halten. Und deswegen hat man aktuell so den Eindruck, da sind mehr Treter als Techniker unterwegs. Und die besonders guten Spieler wie in Vinicius werden dann selbst noch rassistisch beleidigt und haben dann wenig Gründe überhaupt in der Liga zu bleiben. Auch wenn da jetzt noch keine, wenn das Vinicius jetzt so noch nicht geäußert hat. Aber wie gesagt, es sind viele Wolken über der Liga und ich tue mich schwer, mich da euphorisch zu äußern über die Liga. Aber ich werde eben auch oft gefragt, was ist da los in der Liga? Wie konnte das sein? Vor einigen Jahren die Klassikos waren der Oberhammer und generell der Meisterschaftskampf. Auch dieses Jahr ist es ein spannender Kampf, aber irgendwie ist es nicht mehr so wie vor einigen Jahren.
Ich sehe da irgendwie viele Parallelen zur Entwicklung der Serie A. In der Mitte der 2010er überalterte Kader, wenig Jugendspieler, Rassismus in Stadien, unattraktive Spielweise und so natürlich auch teilweise immer klischeebehaftet und überspitzt dargestellt, aber unangenehm auf jeden Fall.
Ja, vor allem es sind halt so viele Themen und auch Themen, die zum Teil sind sie genuin sportliche Themen, zum anderen aber der Rassismus gegen Vinicius zum Beispiel, der äußert sich im Fußball kommt aber eigentlich aus der Gesellschaft und ist aber dennoch etwas, was man nicht kleinreden darf. Da ist jetzt neulich der Anfang eines Artikels, ich glaube vom Garten rumgegangen, in dem Roberto Carlos zitiert wurde, der 1997 auch schon rassistisch beleidigt wurde, sich dagegen geäußert hat und dann sagt der Spieler von Barcelona danach, naja, der redet halt sehr viel, der redet vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, er kennt unsere Fans nicht und er war hier nicht lang genug, um sich dazu äußern zu dürfen und dieser Mann, der das gesagt hat, war Pep Guardiola, das ist natürlich auch die bittere Pointe dieses Einstiegs in den Text von Barca, damals Gegenspieler ja quasi von Roberto Carlos, wenn auch nicht direkt auf dem Feld und ohne, dass man jetzt so einzelne Aussagen überbewerten muss, zeigt es aber, wie tiefgreifend diese Probleme sind. Nicht nur in Deutschland haben wir das, das haben wir eben auch in Spanien und das macht es dann so besonders schwierig und etwas Ähnliches. Jetzt kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen, aber ich möchte nur quasi zeigen, wie komplex die Situation ist. Wenn ich vorhin zum Beispiel den spanischen Frauenfußball genannt habe, dann ist es auf Vereinsebene so, dass der FC Barcelona das Maß aller Dinge ist und wahrscheinlich auch in der Champions League wieder sein könnte in diesem Jahr. Wenn man sich da aber das Nationalteam anguckt, dann hast du da ganz andere Probleme. Da sind nämlich 15 Spielerinnen zurückgetreten, weil der Nationaltrainer Rauch Wilder vom Verbandspräsidenten geschützt wird, schon seit ewigen Jahren Trainer ist und die Spielerinnen aber nicht gut behandelt. Man muss sich das vorstellen, da sind 15 der besten Spielerinnen der Welt zurückgetreten. Dieser Mann hat immer noch seinen Job. Er spielt jetzt mit einer zwar immer noch sehr guten BF, also man möchte sie gar nicht BF nennen, aber das sind eben wirklich richtige Stars spielen, nicht mehr fürs Nationalteam, weil sie sagen, mit diesem Trainer können wir nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten. Wie komplex die Probleme sind – da habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht Superliga-Klage gegen La Liga und vor dem EU-Gericht und so weiter und so fort. Also da sind sehr, sehr viele Dinge, die gerade ineinandergreifen. Und Malius, wenn du das so sagst, ich habe ehrlicherweise auch, was das spielerische angeht, auch so leichte Flashbacks und habe so das Gefühl, in La Liga gibt es gerade so ein komplexes Zusammenspiel aus ganz vielen Problemen, die sich sowieso nicht schnell lösen lassen.
Aber es geht irgendwann auch wieder bergauf, also das merke ich ja gerade in Italien, auch wenn das Jugendproblem natürlich noch nicht gelöst ist und das Rassismusproblem sowieso nicht. Aber ansonsten macht es aktuell ja wieder sehr viel Spaß und das passiert dann in Spanien bestimmt auch. Also Nils, da musst du nicht zu pessimistisch langfristig sein, glaube ich.
Es gibt ja auch international dann immer mal noch Zwischenerfolge, wie Areal hat die Europa League gewonnen, Rea Madrid die Champions League, aber allein da der Blick. Atletico war vierte in der Gruppenphase, Barca ist jetzt auch ausgeschieden. Ja, und es ist auch zwischen den Verbänden, also Liga-Verband und Nationalverband, gibt es auch immer viele öffentliche Streits. Das sind zwei Streit-Täne, Rubiales und Tebas, die da sich öffentlich immer wieder so eine Schlammschlacht liefern. Also ich könnte dir noch mehr auflisten über die Preise. Aber die spätene Anschlusszeit, die Copa del Rey, Halbfinale Rückspiele, sind bald um 22 Uhr. Es ist – ja, danke Marius. Ich hoffe auch, dass es besser wird und bestimmt.
Schön, dass du dich hier so positiv eingebracht hast. Wollen wir dann über den Abschiegskampf in der Serie A direkt sprechen?
So das als als kurioses und vielleicht so halbwegs lustiges Thema hinten dran. Das passt dann ja. Oder vielleicht ist es auch traurig. Das können wir dann ja bewerten.
Ja, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, wie du das jetzt meinst. Also der Abschiegskampf, wenn man sich die Tabelle anschaut, dann sieht er ehrlicherweise gar nicht so spannend aus. Wir sehen Sampdoria, da haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen. Immer noch Tabellenletzter, 11 Punkte, Cremonese, 12 Punkte, Verona, dann 17 Punkte und dann gibt es schon eine 3-Punkte-Lücke zu Spezia und Salahnitana hat dann schon 7 Punkte Vorsprung. Dennoch sehe ich da ein grünes W, was hier bei Who's God bedeutet. Cremonese hat gewonnen. Ist das vielleicht ein guter Einstieg in dieses Thema?
Das ist ein sehr guter Einstieg und auch alles, was da unten im Abschiegskampf schlecht ist, das macht vielleicht dieses Positiverlebnis in Cremonese weg. Erstmal vorangestellt, die sind ja auch ins Halbfinale der Coppa Italia eingezogen gegen die Roma, gegen Mourinhos Mannschaft. Und jetzt am Dienstagabend haben sie auch am 24. Spieltag ihren ersten Sieg in der Serie A geholt. Und es war der erste seit Ende Mai 1996, weil sie natürlich auch in der Zwischenzeit nicht in der Serie A gespielt haben. Aber tatsächlich ist da jetzt sozusagen die Euphorie wieder groß, auch wenn es immer noch acht Punkte Rückstand auf Spezia sind, die gerade den Trainer gewechselt haben und selbst auch irgendwie relativ stark in der Krise sind. Also ich glaube, man erhofft sich dadurch jetzt ein bisschen wieder was. Wir haben das ja letztes Jahr, ich glaube, darüber hatte ich auch hier in der Ligatur gesprochen, eben bei Salenitana gesehen, die in der zweiten Saisonhilfe eine unglaubliche Serie hingelegt haben. Und danach, ich glaube, die hatten sieben Punkte oder so nach den ersten 20 Spielen und sind dann nicht abgestiegen am Ende.
Aber gibt es denn da irgendwelche sportlichen Gründe für, also wenn ich mir diesen Einzug ins Halbfinale der Coppa Italia angucke, also 2-1 gegen Roma gewonnen im Achtelfinale, 2-2 gegen Napoli dann im Elfmeterschießen gewonnen, das war schon sehr gut, aber das können ja auch, da kommt man ja manchmal in so einen Lauf rein. Und du hast es ja jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen eingeordnet, wie lange man nicht mehr gewonnen hat. Hat sich auch was verändert, deiner Meinung nach?
Es gab tatsächlich auch einen Trainerwechsel, der ist jetzt aber auch schon ein paar Wochen her. Da hat man mit Davide Balladini einen ganz erfahrenen Mann für den Abstiegskampf geholt. Und eigentlich war es bei Cremona schon die, oder bei Cremonese die ganze Saison schon so, dass man teilweise relativ gut mitgespielt hat, sich aber dann am Ende nie belohnt hat. Ich finde, die machen eigentlich schon Spaß anzugucken. Die stellen sich nicht komplett hinten rein, die gehen ziemlich giftig rauf und versuchen dann auch nach vorne zu spielen. Sie haben dann mit Dessas zum Beispiel auch einen guten Stürmer da vorne drin. Wenn sie nicht so wenig Punkte geholt hätten, dann würde man nicht meinen, dass das eine Mannschaft ist, die jetzt unbedingt so krass dick im Abstiegskampf drin ist. Ich glaube, dass diese Erfolgserlebnisse da irgendwie noch ein bisschen was freisetzen können und dass es zumindest nicht der einzige Sieg in dieser Saison sein wird am Ende.
Wer wären so die Teams, bei denen du denkst, an denen könnte Krimonese noch vorbeigehen?
Spezia, wie gesagt, da bin ich mir relativ unsicher. Natürlich ist der Leonardo Simplici auch erfahren im Abstiegskampf und da muss man mal sehen, die haben eigentlich auch einen guten Kader mit auch guten Offensivleuten. Soler als Stürmer, der hat auch schon 10 oder 11 Tore geschossen. Also die Qualität ist eigentlich da. Ich hatte dieses eher auf Platz 12 bis 13 getippt vor der Saison. Aber die sind aus diesem Negativstrudel eben bisher nicht herausgekommen. Und die acht Punkte sehe ich nicht als sicher an. Also in den letzten Jahren hat man eigentlich immer so, sage ich mal, 31, 32, 33 Punkte gebraucht, um die Klasse zu halten. Das wird für Cremonesen natürlich super schwierig. Also das sind dann noch 20 Punkte, die sie holen müssten, jetzt aus den verbleibenden 14 Spielen. Die Odds are against them. Was würde man auf Deutsch zu sagen? Die Chancen sind geregelt. Ja, genau. Aber ich meine, warum nicht, wenn die jetzt vielleicht noch aus den nächsten zwei, drei Spielen irgendwie noch so 6, 7 Punkte holen, womöglich, ich habe gerade nicht auf dem Schirm, wer die nächsten Gegner sind, aber die haben ja auch die Roma geschlagen. Also warum nicht? Also dann wäre man, wenn das BC eben die Punkte nicht holt, wäre man da relativ dicht dran. Und Hellas als 18. jetzt mit 17 Punkten ist zwar eigentlich auch von der individuellen Qualität her besser besetzt, aber kriegt das halt auch eigentlich die ganze Saison schon nicht vernünftig aufs Feld. Hatten jetzt auch gerade eine zumindest solidere Phase, wo sie nicht jedes Spiel verloren haben, aber nachhaltig in die Erfolgsspur sind sie, das macht ja auch der Punktestand deutlich, eben nicht gekommen. Und also Spezia und Hellas abzufangen, ist auf jeden Fall kein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Also gegen Hellas spielt man noch zu Hause am 32. Spieltag. Ansonsten sind die nächsten Gegner Sassola, Florenz und Monza.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall nicht unmöglich.
Genau. Und dass man die Roma zweimal besiegt hat, das wird Jose Mourinho sicherlich ganz stoisch zur Kenntnis genommen haben, dass er zweimal mit 1 zu 2 unterliegt.
Ich habe heute Morgen gelesen, er war wohl beim U14-Derby, der Roma gegen Lazio, und es ist da negativ aufgefallen. Also das hält ihm wohl noch nach.
Weil er sich zu viel beschwert hat, oder wie?
Ja, genau. Also er hat gesagt, die Spieler sollen Zeit schinden, um zu gewinnen auf dem Bar und solche Sachen.
Wie diese übermotivierten Fußballväter, das ist ja fürchterlich. Andererseits auch relatable auf eine Art und Weise, aber vielleicht nicht die, die man haben möchte. Naja, bleiben wir beim Abstiegskampf. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt zu ungerecht war. Wir wollen über West Ham sprechen in der Premier League. Die hat uns Uli noch als zweites Thema mitbekommen. Wie viel Abstiegskampf ist West Ham? Zwei Punkte Vorsprung hat man aktuell.
Mitten drin, würde ich sagen, das ist der Klassiker im Rasenfunk. Die Bemessungsgrundlage, die man ansetzen muss bei West Ham, im Vergleich zu den letzten beiden Jahren, in denen sie krass überperformed haben. Zumindest habe ich das immer gedacht. Diese Saison bestätigt das durchaus auch. Es läuft wenig zusammen bei den Hammers. Deshalb sind die voll unten drin. Das Witzige ist nur, dass jedes Mal – letztes Wochenende war es wieder so weit – wenn sie dann gegen einen direkten Konkurrenten spielen und es dann heißt, jetzt wird es richtig eng für David Moyes. Wenn er das nicht gewinnt, dann sitzt er zur Disposition. Dann gewinnt er. Dann zeigen sie auch mal wieder, was sie grundsätzlich können. Aber viel zu wenig, viel zu selten. Das ist aber auch ein Thema. Transparent muss ich sein. Ich habe dann schon gedacht, in einem positiven und einem negativen Thema eher. Die negativen Themen – Southampton ist inzwischen Stammgast in der Ligatur gewesen. Das ist wahrscheinlich langweilig. Leeds United mit neuem Trainer, da kann man noch nicht so richtig viel dazu sagen. Jetzt, nachdem es jetzt eineinhalb Spiele waren, also ein Pokalspiel, das ich nicht überbewerten will, ein Ligaspiel. Und auch das ist, glaube ich, hier diskutiert worden. Daher habe ich mal West Ham mitgebracht.
Ja, finde ich auch super. Denn der Blick auf den Abstiegskampf generell ist ja sehr interessant. Du hast ja gerade den Trainerwechsel in Leeds schon angesprochen. Das haben vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Die haben eben 22 Punkte. West Ham zur Erinnerung nochmal 23. Everton 21, Bournemouth 21. Und wenn wir nach oben gucken, sind Wolverhampton die Wanderers mit 24. Und Leicester mit 24. Jetzt auch nicht so weit weg. Und man könnte sogar noch weiter hochgehen. Also es ist sehr eng da hinten drin. Und es stehen eben so manche Namen mit dabei, mit denen jetzt nicht zu rechnen war. West Ham, sicherlich auch Everton. Bei allem, was da schiefgelaufen ist, dass man nur 21 Punkte hat, ist natürlich trotzdem mehr als nur ärgerlich. Was glaubst du, wer hat da unten gerade die besten Karten? Und um wen musste man sich Sorgen machen?
Also bei Leicester glaube ich, ist die Qualität im Kader zu gut. Die habe ich nicht mehr drin. Also die beiden mit 24 Punkten, die würde ich allein schon deshalb rausnehmen auch. Bei den Wolves ist es das Gleiche. Die sind qualitativ zu hochwertig. Und dann muss ich es eigentlich von hinten her rechnen. Southampton, die machen mir richtig Angst, so wie die spielen. Da gab es jetzt unter dem neuen Trainer, der jetzt inzwischen fix ist, also Ruben Sayes, hat jetzt zumindest mal das Magnetat bekommen bis zum Saisonende. Das sah einspiel-lang okay aus, bestenfalls okay. Das war auch nicht gut. Aber sie haben zumindest nichts zugelassen und haben dann vorne irgendwas reingemurmelt. Das war okay, aber um die habe ich richtig Angst. Das glaube ich grundsätzlich, auch wenn die auch einen neuen Besitzer haben, nochmal ordentlich investiert im Winter. Da sind ein, zwei interessante Spieler dabei, aber aus meiner Sicht keine totalen Soforthilfen. Auch um die habe ich Angst. Das sind die zwei, die ich fast sicher als Abstiegskandidaten habe. Dann wird es die große Frage. Everton hat jetzt mit John Deitsch einen neuen Trainer, der glaube ich sehr, sehr gut dahin passt, soweit irgendwann mal irgendwas zusammengepasst hat bei Everton. Da ist gleich noch dahinter. Bei Leeds bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher, auch wenn ich die Trainer-Verpflichtung mit Javi Gracia jetzt mag. Einer, der eher mal erst mal das Zentrum zusperrt und nicht hau-ruck spielt wie Jesse Marsch. Ich mag das grundsätzlich, aber ich fürchte, einen von den beiden wird es erwischen, weil – und da sind wir dann wieder bei West Ham – West Ham am Ende immer noch zu leicht, nicht sehr viel, aber leicht zu gut ist. A, was die individuelle Qualität betrifft, und B, was zumindest den spielerischen – also spielerisch darf man ihn ja nennen – aber was den Plan betrifft, den David Moyes hat, den die Mannschaft kennt zuallermeist und in der Regel auch umsetzt. Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr, dass sie nicht tun, was er will, sondern es ist deutlich zurückgegangen in Sachen Effizienz. Da waren sie in den letzten Jahren so krass drüber, dass sie in dieser Saison merken, wenn sie mal leicht drunter sind. Sie sind gar nicht deutlich unter den Expected Goals, aber leicht drunter, weil Chancenverwertung nicht so gut sind und weil vor allen Dingen die Flanken, die essenziell sind für das Spiel der Hammers, nicht genau kommen, nicht verwertet werden können. In der Folge gibt es auch keine zweiten Bälle. Und so einfach ist es dann manchmal schon zu erklären, warum es nicht läuft. Weil die Werte läuferisch etc. sind alle ziemlich gleich. Auch die Pressingwerte sind alles ziemlich gleich in den Vorsaisons, aber da krankt es.
Ja, und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen generell an der Ausrichtung, weil wenn du sagst, die Expected Goals, die sind ungefähr Pari Pari. Also das, was man statistisch gesehen hätte machen sollen, hat man auch gemacht. Dann würde ich sagen, naja, aber 23 Tore aus 24 Spielen sind ja dann auch wirklich nicht viel.
Nee, also sie sind schon in den Expected Goals deutlich drunter, wenn man es jetzt in dieser Saison vergleicht. Ich habe jetzt gemeint in den Vorsaisons.
Okay, falsch verstanden.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nur komisch ausgedrückt in einer allgemeinen sehr langen Antwort, wie mir aufgefallen ist. Auf eine gar nicht so lange Frage und gar nicht so komplexe Frage. Aber so ist es manchmal. Nein, es ist tatsächlich so. Die Abschlussqualitäten sind zu schwach. Es gibt eigentlich nur einen Spieler, der im 1 gegen 1 was richtig machen kann. Also klar, es gibt Jared Bohn, der viel Tempo hat, aber nicht so richtig im 1 gegen 1 Frontal eine Lösung findet. Der Einzige, der da generell mal Kreatives mitbringt, ist Seid Ben Rama. Und er spielt aber zu selten in der Startformation. Witzigerweise gibt es die Korrelation sehr wohl. Wenn er spielt, sind sie sehr viel erfolgreicher. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass er ihn immer bringt, der David Beuys.
Ich hatte mal vor, das ist jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her, da war glaube ich Raphael Honigstein hier zu Gast. Und der hat damals zu mir gesagt, weil da habe ich ihn auch nach dem Abstiegskampf gefragt, dann hat er gesagt, boah, also das interessiert halt hier die Leute gar nicht so sehr, außer halt die Fans der beteiligten Vereine. Ist das denn immer noch so, wenn jetzt auch so große Namen, ohne jetzt anderen zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber eben so größere Namen mit unten drin hängen?
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Also klar hat jetzt nicht die Aufmerksamkeit von Manchester United oder wenn bei Liverpool irgendwas nicht läuft. Das ist klar. Aber ich finde schon, dass alleine durch die Teilnahme, sei ich jetzt mal unfreiwillig, am Abstiegskampf von Leeds und Everton und deren chaotischen Dinge, die da so gelaufen sind, dass da schon ein großes Augenmerk drauf liegt. Das finde ich schon. Vielleicht hat Marius vorher auch mal kurz gesagt, das mag dann auch immer eine Frage des Konsums sein. Ich hänge jetzt nicht auf den Seiten ab, die jetzt so klassisch der Mainstream sind, sondern versuche dann schon immer etwas tiefer zu gehen. Aber ich finde, dass es da sehr wohl berichtet wird. Und es gibt auch von denen, die es gucken, also sowohl in unserem Inland jetzt als auch in England und was ich so mitkriege umliegend, durchaus Teilnahme am Abstiegskampf. Das würde ich so nicht sehen. Aber kann auch sein, dass das tatsächlich eine Entwicklung ist. Da muss ich mal drüber nachdenken, ob das früher nur nicht so war und das jetzt so ist. Oder ob ich einfach schon viel zu tief in dieser Bubble bin. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Es hilft wahrscheinlich dann nicht, dass man da einen wöchentlichen Podcast darüber macht. Aber das haben ja hier drei von euch vieren miteinander gemeinsam. Dann lasst uns noch ein letztes Mal nach Frankreich blicken. Michi, da hast du uns noch PSG als Thema mitgebracht. Wir haben PSG gegen den FC Bayern gesehen. Da hat man 0-2-1 verloren. Ich glaube, dieses Spiel, wer sich dafür interessiert, der hat das mitverfolgt und auch nachgelesen, wie das ungefähr gelaufen ist. Danach gab es ein aufsehenerregendes 4-3 gegen Lidl. Da lag man lange Zeit zurück, hat dann spät ausgeglichen und noch später den Siegtreffer erzielt. Und dann ein sehr viel erwartetes Aufeinandertreffen mit Marseille, denn Marseille war der Verfolger, von dem man dachte, die könnten vielleicht an den Fersen von PSG hängenbleiben. Wenn ich jetzt dieses 3 zu 0 sehe, ist es dann so, dass jetzt wieder alles super ist bei PSG und alles hat sich beruhigt und alle gehen geregelt ihrer Arbeit nach oder ist es wie immer bei PSG?
Sehr schöne rhetorische Frage. Auf keinen Fall. Ruhig ist es da sowieso nie. Natürlich hat der Sieg die Wogen geglättet, auch von der Intensität her haben die Marseille wirklich niedergerungen. Gerade am Anfang war das ein sehr starkes Spiel. Und da hat PSG Qualitäten gezeigt, die sie lang verborgen gehalten haben. Hatten dann noch diesen, ich nenne es jetzt mal Schicksalsschlag, mit Kim Bap-P, der sich verletzt hat, der aus der Jugend ist, der ein Urgestein ist, der von jedem geachtet wird und deshalb auch einer der Führungsspieler ist und eben vorher schon lange verletzt war und dann nochmal verletzt vom Platzmuster, der jetzt länger ausfällt. Und das hat schon ein bisschen was bewirkt, hat schon so einen Push gegeben dem gesamten Team. Das ist schon positiv. Allerdings bleibt dieser Verein eine Ansammlung von Spielern, die, wenn sie wollen, Weltklasse sind und wenn sie aber eben nicht wollen oder wenn ein, zwei, drei nicht wollen, die dann auch mal verlieren können gegen Mannschaften aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte. Und ich glaube, wenn die jetzt gegen Bayern weiterkommen, dann wird es auch in der Liga wieder besser, weil es kann natürlich auch noch mal Schwung geben. Aber wenn die ausschalten, dann wird es auch noch mal um den Trainer gehen. Dann wird es um die Offensivreihe gehen. Dann wird es vor allem um die Ausrichtung gehen. Es drängt sich jetzt gerade die Frage auf, wie spielt man denn gegen Bayern? Spielt man mit einer Dreierkette hinten und zwei Offensiven außen, obwohl Kimpempe ausfällt und dann natürlich einen Innenverteidiger ran muss, den man mit Milan Skriniar gern gehabt hätte, schon seit einem Jahr, der aber nicht gekommen ist. Und man dann eben einen Talent einsetzen muss. Oder man opfert einen aus der offensiven Dreierreihe, was eigentlich unmöglich ist, weil das hat schon Maurizio Pochettino versucht und da ging es schief. Bei Neymar und bei Messi wird sich das nicht mehr getraut. Und bei Mbappé schon gleich.
Aber wird denn Neymar spielen können? Weil gegen Marseille zum Beispiel haben sie ja quasi mit so einem 3-5-2 gespielt, mit Mbappé und Messi vorne drin. Und wenn ich mir einfach nur – ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, aber ich sehe hier 1 zu 0 Mbappé nach Vorlage Messi, 2 zu 0 Messi nach Vorlage Mbappé, 3 zu 0 Mbappé nach Vorlage Messi und Messi hat auch noch einen Aluminium-Treffer mit dabei gehabt. Also es scheint jetzt nicht so schlecht funktioniert zu haben.
Genau, richtig. Bei dem Spiel auf keinen Fall. Aber es gab eben auch die Spiele davor. Seit der Winterpause haben die keine gute Bilanz gehabt. Das war meiner Ansicht nach das erste Spiel, wo sie wirklich vollumfänglich überzeugt haben. Natürlich sind sie die besten Freunde, wenn sie dann gut sind, wenn sie dann natürlich auch motiviert sind gegen so ein Team. Und im Pokal gab es eben die Niederlage dann. Also im Pokal sind sie gegen OM rausgeflogen. Und da hatte sich dann ganz plötzlich keiner mehr liebt. Das ist halt ein sehr schwankendes Konstrukt dabei, PSG. Und das mündet dann eben in einer Bilanz, die dann so eine Tabellenkonstellation wie vor ein paar Wochen noch herstellt, wo PSG keine 8 Punkte – ich glaube aktuell haben sie 8 Punkte Vorsprung. Also da hatten sie zeitweise auch mal nur 2 Vorsprung. Und dann war Monaco auf den Fersen. Dann war teilweise Lance auf den Fersen. Lance hat es ja auch geschlagen. Lance, die keiner auf den Zettel hatte oder wenige vor der Saison. Und ja, da haben viele gehofft, dass so etwas wie mit Lille vor ein paar Jahren passiert, dass irgendjemand ihnen den Drang abläuft. Und Marseille war da schon die Mannschaft, die das am ehesten hätte tun können, aber jetzt mit 8 Punkten Vorsprung. Naja, viel wird da wahrscheinlich nicht mehr passieren.
Da gibt es ja wirklich erstaunliche Parallelen zu Bayern. Aber das will ich jetzt nicht überstrapazieren, vor allem weil wir über Bayern nur nicht wissen, ob die es wieder schaffen, sich einen Vorsprung herauszuspielen. Den haben sie nämlich jetzt gerade nicht. Was ist denn so dein Gefühl mit Blick auf dieses Rückspiel? Was erwartest du?
Boah, das ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Also, lass PSG ein Tor machen und alles läuft gut. Oder lass die nächste Remodelle passieren und dann schlägt Bayern wieder zurück. Weil dieses Gebilde bei PSG durch eine Erschütterung eben zum Einsturz gebracht werden kann, was man im Herbst noch nicht gedacht hatte, weil sie da sehr stark performt haben. Ein Neymar schien in der Spur zu sein, der zum Medientermin, wie es vorher noch nicht gemacht hatte, durchweg pünktlich kam. Ein Messi, der sich integriert hat, und ein Mbappé, der sich mit allen verstanden hat, weil er jetzt einen unfassbar hochdotierten Vertrag in der Tasche hatte. Das ging eben verloren. Deswegen glaube ich immer noch nicht, dass dieser Kader ausgewogen genug ist, um Almstand zu halten. Ich tippe darauf, dass PSG weiterkommt. Aber das steht auf ganz wackeligen Füßen. Das ist jetzt ein Tipp. Aber weil ich weiß, wie leicht es ist, diese Mannschaft aus dem Konzept zu bringen. Ganz schwer zu sagen. Es ist fast 50-50. Aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen 55. Zu 45 für PSG, trotz der Hinspielerlage.
Am nächsten Mittwoch, den 8. März, wird das Rückspiel steigen. Wenn ich mir etwas wünschen könnte, dann wäre es ein Shootout zwischen Eric-Maxime Choupo-Moting und Juan Bernat. Genau, Uli Hoeneß wird dann schon auch teilnehmen. Da wird dann schon der Saun den richtigen Querschnitt machen. Der Saun produziert ja auch die Bilder. Wenn ich das richtig gemerkt habe, ist es ja in der Champions League so, dass die Rechteinhaber die Bilder produzieren. Aber bevor ich mich da jetzt weiter aufs Glatteis bewege, eine abschließende Frage an euch alle vier. Und dann seid ihr entlassen. Du darfst dann gleich loslegen, Michi. Welches Spiel jetzt in der Liga – ich will jetzt nicht PSG gegen Bayern hören – am Wochenende ist in deiner Meinung nach besonders bemerkenswert. Und sollte man sich vielleicht nachverfolgen?
In meiner Liga? Also in Frankreich?
Also in Frankreich, ja.
Ganz klar, Startrennen gegen Olympique Marseille. Die spielen am Sonntagabend. Und da geht es dann – also im Rennen ist aktuell, ich meine, fünf oder sechs Punkte hinter Marseille als Fünfter. Marseille ist Zweiter. Also da können die heranrücken. Und auch an Laus und Monaco, die noch davor stehen. Und spielerisch wird es total interessant.
Das kann man sich angucken in der Liga. Marius, in der Serie A, welches Match to watch gibt es da?
Ich würde zwei auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Und das ist natürlich nominell. Schon allein damit begründet am Freitagabend empfängt Napoli Lazio. Und Napoli kann man sich im Moment einfach immer geben. Uli hatte ja vorhin schon einmal Ozyman angesprochen. Und das United braucht einen Stürmer, der aus jeder Position Traumtore oder Tore erzielen kann. Ozyman kann das und macht auch Traumtore aus den spitzesten Winkeln. Und am Sonntagabend empfängt die Roma Juve. Das wird sicherlich nicht das attraktivste Fußballspiel, aber da steckt natürlich sehr viel drin und sehr viel Emotion. Und ich glaube, das kann man sich dann auch ganz gut geben.
Uli, was wartet auf uns in der Premier League?
Ich kann natürlich nur eins nennen, Arsenal gegen Bournemouth, weil der Kommentator sensationell ist. Im Ernst, ich glaube, Liverpool United ist schon heiß. Und ich freue mich persönlich auch sehr auf Montagabend, Brentford gegen Fulham.
Das ist einmal der Obvious-Tipp und einmal dann noch der Feinschmecker, der Gourmet-Tipp. Sehr schön. Und dann, ja gut, Nils, muss ich dich überhaupt fragen, ob wir uns was angucken sollen?
Genug gemeckert, Leckeres gibt es trotzdem in der Liga. Ob das Atletico gegen Sevilla ist, Betis gegen Real Madrid, aber vor allem Sonntag 16.15 Uhr, Barca gegen FC Valencia. Ich meine, Barca kriegt jetzt am Donnerstagabend die dritte Niederlage in Folge. Mal schauen. Und der FC Valencia, neuer Trainer Ruben Barracher, hat das erste Spiel verloren, dann zu Hause gewonnen. Also dort ist ein bisschen die Hoffnung zurück. Sie sind ja noch auf Abstiegsplatz. Und deswegen wird das, glaube ich, ein besonderes, auch kampfvolles Duell, Barca gegen Valencia am Sonntagnachmittag.
Aber das klingt wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr. Uli Hebel für die Premier League, Nils Kern für La Liga, Marius Soyke zur Serie A und Michael Postl mit einem fantastischen Debüt zur Ligue 1. Ich werde alle eure Social-Media-Handels verlinken in den Show notes. Danke euch vier, dass ihr mal Zeit für die Ligatur hattet. Ihr dürft jetzt alle gemeinsam sagen, gerne. Gott, jetzt fühle ich mich wie so ein Lehrer, der morgens begrüßt wird. Naja, egal. Ich danke auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit, wenn ihr es nicht mitbekommen habt. Letzten Donnerstag ist ein Kurzpass zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga erschienen. Und es wird jetzt dann die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz Nummer 400 geben. Die nehme ich am Sonntagabend auf. Und am Montagabend nehme ich dann den nächsten Kurzpass zur Frauen-Bundesliga auf. Es wird durchgeballert im Rasenfunk, wie ihr es nicht anders verdient habt. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt uns. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club ist die Adresse der Wahl. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder. Bleibt gesund.